non
j'ai en mémoire coluche sur une scène et
l'emprise progressive qui l'installait
avec son public et je me souviens être
littéralement tombé de mon siège plié en
deux par le rire
il racontait la formation du
gouvernement jean pierre soisson acquis
giscard venait de proposer un marocain
demandait à être nommé ministre de la
gare de lyon
le train disait-il je connais je les
prix une fois cette histoire ne fait pas
partie des inoubliables proposé par
fixot mais tant d'autres figurent dans
ce recueil on retrouvera ici par l'écrit
le crs arabe qui est certainement l'un
des témoignages les plus juste jamais
imaginé sur le racisme et la lâcheté
ordinaire est aussi le type et repère
dans lequel coluche pose ces questions
prodigieuse quel âge avait rimbaud
quelle différence y at il entre un
pigeon coluche avait du génie mais
comment ton restant dénier à un homme
qui faisait dire à jean lecanuet je ne
suis ni pour ni contre bien au contraire
qu'ils appellent le pape jean paul ii et
j'en retiens 1 et qui définit de la
sorte les artichauts un plat de pauvre
con t'as fini d'en manger ton à puce
dans ton assiette que quand a commencé